poor thing you need to rest it's okay we've got you now it's alright to let
yourself relax we're here to reassure you all right don't mind our fluffy tails in fact you
might find it quite pleasant to be wrapped up in between us don't you I can sense that your
head is running 100 miles a minute but just take a moment to breathe one big inhale and one big exhale
it's okay to take your time you know that right not everything has to be now now now no wonder you
feel so stressed when you put such an immense amount of pressure on yourself who told you to do
that do you listen to everyone it gives you terrible advice but I'm being serious when I say just
take a moment to calm down you need some good sleep so I'll just have to make sure that I put
you into the deepest slumber I can manage in that case you might even need me to tell she was
wrong you know about what she said you put too much pressure on yourself you also put too much on
your plate at the same time I know you like being the workhorse and you like getting to the other side
but that's gonna have an effect on you if you sacrifice your sleep for it that's sacrificing
your health do you understand me good then just take a moment and try your best to tune out what's
going on around you it's just us three together in this moment we're guddled up we're looking after
you hopefully on the other end of this conversation you can feel yourself slowly dressed in all of this
sleep it's been a while since you've had a nice rest I can tell by your eyes it's the biggest
giveaway you know they aren't cold the windows to your soul for nothing it's alright to close your
eyes even if you don't think you'll fall asleep you can still listen to our words or at least the
sounds that we make do you like being wrapped up in our tails it's very fluffy isn't it I love
seeing people's reactions to just how incredibly soft they are why don't I try to reassure you a
little while you focus on how soft how soothing our tails are it's okay to worry but don't worry
you're so sick you are allowed to make mistakes you're only human after all so far you've made it
through 100% of all of your bad days and that makes you so incredibly strong you've been able to push
through everything even when life gets hard and you always come out on top on the other side don't
you that makes you so very brave in my eyes sometimes you just need reassurance and that's okay
I'm glad to be able to do that for you it's a pleasure in all honesty so thank you for listening
to me the best way that we can support you right now is getting you to sleep I think
it may seem like a small act but a well-rested mind can help navigate what the world has to offer
sometimes it can be confusing why we have a negative experience you may think to yourself why me
why now I present to you a question
if everything in your life was good then would you really appreciate the good times
I think sometimes with the bad it makes the good times even sweeter
that's what I think anyway you might not agree or you might even be asleep by now
just from our whispers alone wouldn't that be adorable humans really do work themselves silly
then I should be extra mindful a pamper you in a pure bliss line
good night dear human get as much rest as you need
it's time to let it all go and enter the deep slumber